happy Monday reject nation it's Greg
Alba here a trailer for another movie
from retired director Steven Soderbergh
is out it's called unsane just dropped
today I'm excited to check this trailer
out Soderbergh he's one of our best
directors I feel before going into this
couple of things number one shout out
today for Austin Moore patron of the day
shout out number two shout out to the
Stardust app we are climbing in
followers right now over there people we
have over a hundred twenty post
exclusive reactions or reviews thirty
seconds long only for any film TV show
or trailer right now I'm still
recovering from a high fever so I'm
gonna try to catch the Maze Runner later
on today and then shoot a review for it
so if I happen to catch it that review
will be up late if not it will
definitely be on the Stardust app a lot
of your favorite youtubers are using
this app as well so make sure to
download the app and follow us first at
the real rejects people anyway onto some
son of our daughters poor David
[Music]
[Music]
especially yourself if you just do as I
ask there's some mistake by signing this
you do you know how many calls the cops
get like that every week those are some
crazy people man
[Music]
Oh Oh No
that bad call crap
[Music]
[Music]
oh man a trailer had me just super
uncomfortable the entire time it's crazy
to see the range that Soderbergh has
last year he comes out with Logan lucky
totally different type of movie more
like the Ocean's eleven type year this
is more like the films he did such as
contagion or side effects real
psychological deterioration side effects
not a lot with personality disorder so
he's dealing with that here except
there's a much more visual aesthetic to
it I love the digital camera touched
that sotobro decided to shoot this film
with is that first I was thinking this
looks a little bit like 28 days later
and as it kept going it does have sort
of that tone that vibe which makes all
this feel a lot more realistic a lot
more eerie
I don't know how this films gonna play
out it looks like that's gonna deal with
some murder mystery I imagine there's
gonna be some twist endings maybe Claire
Foy I think it's her name is a murderer
a lot of the times you see these movies
where the twist ending is oh they have a
split personality disorder and here the
set up of this film is that she has a
split personality disorder that even one
of the doctors or nurses who's treating
her is the person who she always
envisioned as her stalker that is super
creepy because the whole time it's shot
in a way where you feel like you're
watching a documentary or some type of
found footage really what we're seeing
is the projection of whatever's coming
out of her mind which makes you feel
like you're just in her mindset knowing
Soderbergh this is gonna have some great
tension some great build-up I imagine
this is gonna be something where it's
gonna be a great character study plus
some awesome psychological thrills
combined I don't know what camera
they're shooting this on this looks like
it's shot on an iPhone possibly I
wouldn't be surprised if that's a bit of
reveal cuz I remember he did a film
called mosaic which was launched as like
a smartphone app so I wouldn't be
surprised if this was shot entirely on
an iPhone people are doing that now and
man Soderbergh is really setting that
bar anyone can do anything yeah this is
something I'm super interested in seeing
the performances look great it looks
tense it looks creepy
I think it's shot on an iPhone which
just makes me want to see it even more
because
whenever I hear that kind of concept I
hope that the point of it being shot on
iphone is well justified
either way the camera quality just makes
it feel that much more realistic and
eerie ooh good job Soderbergh anyway
patron the day shot out really fast for
Austin Moore
Austin Moore is a longtime subscriber of
the real rejects recently became a
patron he's been watching us for years
now I've definitely seen his name in
common boxes here and there he actually
has a channel disturbed fan 0 7 1 7
production and I watched the first video
link he sent over is his Lego Star Wars
Jedi Hunt fan film so basically he makes
a Star Wars fan film does a lot of the
voices does the animation and it's all
in Lego format but it's actually really
cool and super badass and there's some
really good voice-over acting in there
I'm gonna put a link in the description
box for you guys to go check it out
because Austin more greatly deserves
some views on this it's got 6,000 views
right now but he needs more because this
[ __ ] needs to get promoted
anyway Austin thanks so much for being a
longtime subscriber man love you buddy
shout out to Michigan you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified every
time one of our videos is up and make
sure to download it and follow us on the
starters to have people